[Alkış]
alanında uzun yıllardır arı ürünleri
çalışıyorum ve Aslında bugün size
girişimcilik hikayelerinden bahsedeceğim
Az önce gördüğümüz videoda
[Müzik]
dum Aslında ben ara ürünleri alanında
uzmanımızın yıllardır bu alanda
çalışıyorum İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi
güzel mühendisliği bölümünde
1996 yılında
tamamladım bölümünde mezun olduktan
sonra arıcılık sektörüne girdim ve
yaklaşık
10 yani 96 2000 yılından beri tamamen
bu set tamamen
aracı kremi çalışma lisanssız çalışma ve
yüksek lisans çalışma ve doktora
çalışmamda ara ürünleri üzerine Hatta bu
alanda girişimci olduktan sonra bir de
işletme masrafı yaptım Yine içimde ve
ara ürünlerin uluslararası Pazarlama
strate
jileri birlikte bu alanda 4 farklı
diplomaya sahip oldum diyebilirim ama
beni asıl girişimci yapan bu alandaki bu
bilgi ve deneyimin üstüne oğlumda
Yaşadığım bir bağışıklık sistemi
problemi oldu Ondan da kısaca bahsetmek
istiyorum oğlum 11 aylıktan itibaren ilk
oğlu kısık ateşleniyordu belki içimizde
benzer bir tabloyu yaşamış olan
lar Neredeyse her ay
kalite ve bu ateş hiçbir şekilde
düşmüyor mutlaka antibiyotik kullanmak
gerekiyor antibiyotik kullandıktan sonra
düşüyor Kısa bir süre için sonra
bırakınca tekrar çıkıyor 5 yaşına kadar
böyle devam eden bir süreç yaşadık Bu
arada annem babam da doktor Annem de
çocuk
yani Türk camiasında bir şekilde
içindeyim ama bir şekilde çözülemeyen
bir sorunla baş başa kaldık
ve 5 yıl boyunca Bunlar devam etti 5
yılın sonunda başka bir rahatsızlıkla
baş başa kaldık henüz adı verilen bir
rahatsızlık Bilmiyorum daha önce hiç
Duydunuz mu açıkçası doktor bana ismini
telaffuz edene kadar Ben hayatımda hiç
duymamıştım ve gerçekten çok korkutucu
Bir rahatsızlık kanın damar dışında
sızması olarak tanımlanıyor ve
uğurluklar şeklinde kollarda bacaklarda
morluklar şeklinde beliriyor son derece
korkutucu bir tablo yani yeşil tertip
edersiniz ki 5 yaşındaki evladığında
bunları gerçekten çok korkmuştum ama 18
Doktor gezdikten sonra son
gittiğimiz sosyalim
ki bugün ve bağışıklık sistemini
düzeltebilirsek evladımızı
düzeltebileceğiniz dedi ama ben bir
gıdan mühendisi olarak takdir edersiniz
ki çocuğumuz zaten çok dikkatli
besliyorum bu çok özeniyorum Yani bizi
hastalandığı için de zaten elimden gelen
her şeyi yapıyorum bil
diğim
içindesin
o zaman da tabii yıllardan
[Müzik]
henüz ülkemizde arı sütü yapımı polis
üretimi yok ve Çin'den geliyor bir tane
olarak ve içinden gelen Aslında
ürünlerde doğal bir takım katkı
maddeleriyle çoğaltılmış Yani sağ ve
doğal Probiyotik gelmiyor içinden
maalesef bir takım kalktılar
polislermiş Ama içinde Profesör olmayan
kişilere geliyor ve biraz daha ürünler
de bunlarla üretiliyor Dolayısıyla ben
de bunu uzmanıyım yani uzmanlığı
Dolayısıyla aramızda bunu tespit
edebiliyorum dedim ki Doktor Eğer hocam
doğal bulamıyorum o zaman niye kendini
Ne biliyorsun diye sordu bana Hoca da
şimdi beni bu soru bugün girişimci yapan
soru oldu aslında Tabii Öncelikle o
zaman henüz kovanlarımız yok ve
arıcılardan rica ettik kendi üretiyor
musunuz sizden alabilir miyiz diye
birçok aracı emretmiyor Ya kimse talep
etmediği için üretmiyor ya nasıl
öğretebileceğini
bilmediği ya da aslında o hayvanın
farkında olmadığı için üretiliyor yani
ne olduğunu ve nasıl üreteceğini Aslında
faydalı bir şey olduğunu bilmiyor Hatta
çöpe atıyorum o tüketiliyor muydu diye
soranlar
sindiremiyor mutlaka özür dileyerek saf
hale Damla formuna getirilmesi lazım
işte o teknolojiyi de mutlaka normal
gerektiriyor kendimde laboratuvarda özür
dilerim
sonra bağışıklık hücrelerinin sayısında
bir doktorla da ölçüyoruz sürekli olarak
tam iki katına çıktığını gözlemledim
tabi bu arada şeyi söylüyorum bu altı ay
ki eve kapalı
okula git Yok böyle bir süreçten
bahsediyor
ve gerçekten de Baş
lıklı Kız güzeldi
kesin zamanlı olarak ateşlenme problemi
işte alerjileri vardı Onlar da eş
zamanlı olarak birçok şey düzeldi hem de
bu şifaya görünce dedim ki yani madem
böyle bir Şifa var doğada ve Madem ki
insanda bundan faydalanabilir böyle bir
imkan da var Neden
bu ihtiyaçların herkeste bu doğal
ürünlere kolaylıkla uğraşamasın İşte bu
soru beni girişimci yapan soru oldu ben
şimdi burada herkese sormak istiyorum
arıların doğaya katkısının farkında
mısın şimdi arıların doğaya bir katlasın
bana Biz daha toplanan bir katkısı oğlu
Bana oğlumun sağlığını bana hediye
ettiler Aslında olduğunu da hediye
ettiler yani bence şu an hala
hastalıklarda mücadele veriyorduk Ama 17
yaşında sağlıklı bir çocuk haline geldi
ama bunun dışında birçok faydası daha
var
tikleri doğaya
yaptıkları canlılar şu an dünyada
tükettiğimiz 100 önemli gıdanın Arılar
sayesinde üretildiğini biliyor muydunuz
Eğer ara olmazsa tarım olmaz tarım
Olmazsa da
insan bakın tozlaşmanın Yani bitkisel
üretimin %80'i dünyada Arılar sayesinde
gerçekleşiyor bir arı hayatı boyunca
300.000 çiçeğe uçabiliyor bir kovan arı
yaklaşık 60 milyar çiçeği ziyaret
edebiliyor
ki aslında
hayatı benim hayatı kaç gün biliyor
musunuz sadece 45 gün 45 günlük ömründe
hiç durmadan çalışarak hem kendisine hem
duaya hem insanlığa faydalı olan
dünyadaki Bence en kutsal canlı ara
onlara çok şey borçluyuz onların
değerinin farkında olmalıyız onlara
arılara ve aralara bakan arıcılarımızda
da sahip çıkmalıyız Çünkü Einstein'ın
bir sözü var biliyorsunuz dünyada
son halinde insanoğlunun sadece BL
ot yıl daha kastettiği bu değerleri
olmazsa gıda betim olmayacak ve gıda
olmasa da insanlık olamayacak bunun
kastediyordu çok da doğru söylüyordu
bakın Birleşmiş Milletler gıda yatarım
örgütünün verilmediğine göre buradayım
%100'dü elma brokolisi
kayısının %56'sı arıların yaptığı
tozlaşma sayesinde üretiliyor Bunlar
sadece birkaç veri bunun gibi daha
yüzlercesi var
Peki nedir bu aslında Propolis dediğimiz
madde Propolis Aslında arıların
ağaçlardan topladığı
ve şu bir an
tioksi Arılar bu maddeyi ağaçlarda
fındık şurada gördüğünüz Petek
gözlerinin içine katlıyorlar niye bunu
yapıyorlar aslında gösteriliyorlar Oraya
bir bakterilerimiz mantarlardan
arındırıyorlar tıpkı bir ameliyathaneye
girerken doktorun kendi arındırması gibi
düşünün
ameliyathanemiz seri olması gibi düşünün
Hatta kovanın giriş deliliğini Arılar
oraya da basıp olan öyle girer kendin
istediği eder
doğadaki en güçlü antioksidan
antibakteriyel antiikviral o an madde
değişmiş
Peki literatür ne diyor Aslında yeni bir
maddeden bahsetmiyor oluruz Arılar 20
milyon yıldır
bal üretiyorlar polis üretiyorlar
insanlık faydalanmış mısır
lıların da
reçeli
Bununla ilgili reçeteler kastettiğimiz
zaten görebiliyoruz
literatüre bastığımızda 120.000'in
üstünde akademik yayınlar klinik
çalışmalar var
direnç geliştiremediği bir an
tibiyotik Aynı zamanda da anti Funda One
kitabında kabul etti
var karaciğer koruyucu bağışıklık
sistemini güçlendirici aynı
kanserojen anti diyebilecek Avrupa
ülküsü onun Yolları enfeksiyonlarını
önleyici ağız içi af dilaraları
iyileştirilecek saymakla bitmeyen çok
fazla
Peki diğer maddemiz ne arı süt
ü bakın şurada
iki tanesi daire
var geri kalan arıların hepsi işçi
arıyor ve erkek arı bir tek
ana arı olarak
Aslında arayıp Hollanda'ya Ulaş ütüyle
besliyor işçi Arılar onlar diğer arıları
sadece 3 gün besliyorlar
bunları diğer arılardan yani o sürekli
arı sütüyle beslenen arı diğer arılardan
3 kat 2 kat daha büyük oluyor 30 kat
daha uzun yaşıyor ve her gün yumurta
yumurtluyor Yani bir kraliçe araya
dönüşüyor süper araya dönüşüyor
kraliçe
arıların
vücutlarından salgıladığı bir süt
vücutlarında Tabii ki yine çok fazla
saymakla Bilmem faydaları var Arılar
içinde faydaları var insanlar içinde
ne gibi faydaları var Enerji ve gündelik
arttırıcı metabolizmayı düzenleyici
bağışıklığı güçlendirici
hem de cipsleri korojen sen
tezini arayacağım ve yine antikansörojen
virüs ve bakterilere karşı vücudun
bağışıklık diyor
lardı kalp ve damar sağ
larının değişip Bir de
sperm ve
yumurcak'ın amacı yani ihtiyacın sebebi
kullanılan biliyor internetinizin
tedavisi destek
başka neler var Arılar ne topluyordu
çiçeklerden
ve
baltlıyor topladığı bu polen aslında Hem
tozlaşmanın bir parçası
bunun için
de minerallerinin protein
lerini hastaneden alıyor Arılar hayatı
boyunca doğal ve polenle besleniyor
polenlerin içerisinde bir canlının
yaşaması için ihtiyaç duyulan bütün
besinleri
vitaminler mineraller aminoasitler
Organik asitler proteinler Hatta o kadar
güçlü bir protein içeriği var ki kas
yapmak için şimdi gençler çok popüler
biliyorsunuz kas yapmak
Protein tozu kullanmanıza gerek yok
doğada polen var günde 30'a yakınında
protein içeriyor aynı zamanda bütün
diğer araç içeriyor ve aynı zamanda da
vücudum bir de bağırsak sisteminde
dengeleyici özelliği var
Peki Arılar poleni nasıl tüketiyor Bakın
şu polen bunu bitkiden aldığı hali
Arılar kulenin Hitit gözün içerisine
dolduruyorlar üzerine enzimlerini bırak
ıyor polenin dış kabuğunu sentezi
çözüyorlar bu neneniz daha
sindirilebilir hale getiriyorlar
Yumurtanın kabuğu gibi düşünün polenin
kabuğunu güçlü bir kabuk bunu çözüp
içindeki besinleri açığa çıkarıyorlar
ve de arı ekmeğine dönüştürüyorlar ara
Kendi ekmeğini polenden yapar Merak
etmeyin glüten içermez
dir
polendir Aslında araya ekmeği bu aynı
zamanda arı ekmeğini güçlü bir
Probiyotik yapıyor günde 10 gram arı
ekmeği tükettiğimizde yaklaşık 10 milyar
mutfak yer alıyorsun Yani hem Probiyotik
hem de bütün o polendeki protein vitamin
Evet efendim
bir deneyimiz var kovanda biliyorsunuz
balımız var peki bana nasıl tüketmeliyiz
şimdi ben burada bir Havva'dan bahsettim
hem bal kullanıyorum diyen var mı birkaç
kişi var en güzel Peki bal
kristalleştiği zaman bu normal midir
diye sorsam Evet diyenler
Hayır normal değildir diyenler
ya da bana şeker katılmıştır diyenler
çok iyi Burası çok eğitimli Bir
tonumuzdayız Şu an ilk defa bir salonda
balın kristalleşmesinin normal olduğunu
herkes biliyor Demek ki birilerine
ulaşmış
ız Şimdi Efendim halk kristalleşir açık
renkli ballardan daha hızlı koyu renkli
ballarda daha geç ama her Veya geç
kalanlar kristalleşir ama diyeceksiniz
ki de biz gidiyoruz kitaplarla böyle
Bağlara cam gibi saydam buradan bakınca
gözüküyor Ne bulanıklık var ne kristal
var Bu nasıl oluyor nasıl işlem
uygulanıyor maalesef etiketlerde de
belirtilmiyor ballar süt gibi
70 derecede ısıtılıyor kristalleşmesin
ya da kristalleşmesini geciksin diye ama
besin değeri kayboluyor şimdi bu işte
tüketicideki o
algıyı aslında değiştir
mek işte daha kaliteli bağlıdır diye ama
bu Nehir doğru değil doğal olarak da
aracıların hepsi bilir Doğal olan kr
içindeki polenleri de filtre ediyorlar
böyle cam gibi saydam gözüksün diye o
zaman bir besin değeri ama yani o
bildiğimiz şeker haline geliyor o yüzden
aslında balonu doğru tüketiminde tam
olarak yani aradım da tükettiği halidir
bunları diğer ülkemizde üretelim çünkü
yılda Valla öğretmeninde de bakın
dünyada aslında ikinci
dünyanın önemli acı ülkelerinden
Üstelik de 12.000 farklı bitki çeşidimiz
var Onların 3500'de ülkemize ait
ülkemizi en
demik Peki biz bu doğaları önleriyle
neler yapıyoruz videoda biraz kısaca
izlediğiniz zaman ben kısaca
göstermek istiyorum Biz aslında şu anda
yaklaşık 150 çalışanımızla Arya merkez
imiz
sözleşmeleri aradık modeliyle bütün
ülkemizde üretiyoruz bu ürünleri
yaklaşık 5.000 aracıyla onlarda 550 bin
liralık oranına bakıyorlar ülkemizin her
yerinde üretiyoruz ve tesisimizde
İstanbul'da bulunan tesisimizde 10.500
metrekareye Türkiye'nin en büyük katma
değerli arıyorum
ihraç ediyoruz yani anadolu'muzun bu
değerlerinin dünyaya duyurmaya
çalışıyoruz Şimdi burada çok önemli
bir danışmanı ne dedim
Aşk
çok önemli sadece ürünleri için değil
Doğa ve insanlık ve tarımın geleceği
içinde çok önemli O yüzden biz ne
yapıyoruz biz Aslında sözleşmeleri
ortadan kaldırarak aracının işini
geliştirmesini sağlıyoruz Aracımızın
malzeme ekipman eğitim desteği veriyoruz
ve değersiz herhangi bir karşılık
almadan adamın öğrencisi veriyoruz ve
fiyatı da tabii ki o sahte için ürünleri
de aynı fiyata olmuyor aracının kar elde
edebileceği bir fiyat üzerinde
karşılıklı anlaşıyoruz Ayrıca ürün için
ne satacağım nereye satacağım
endişesinden kurtulduğu zaman
tutabiliyor bu çok önemli
böyle olmaktan çıkarıp
yaratıcı haline getirebiliyoruz
endişelerini ortadan sildiğimiz için
gece yüksek kaliteli verimli
ürünleri bir daha yapıyoruz sattığımız
her ürünü elde ettiğimiz gelir %1'i
böyle kumbaraya
[Müzik]
bakmalarına
ve daha fazla arı demek daha fazla
tozlaşma demek karbon emisyonların
azalması yeşillik çoğalması demek
Böylece arıların ve
arıların doğaya katkısının konusunda da
yani bu konuda da toplumsal bilinci
arttırmayı hedefliyoruz Evet efendim çok
teşekkür
beni dinlediğiniz için sorularınız varsa
Hadi bakalım çok teşekkür
[Alkış]